f's in the chat for carl
what the hell is spitting up android
blood and three cheers for the bucket
headband
fatality praise saul episodes eight and
nine of raised by wolves are out and we
have even greater news that the show
has officially been picked up for season
two in this video we'll be going over
tons of new theories like
what's in the polyhedron is there a new
third faction we haven't seen yet
and the hidden secrets found on hbo's
raised by wolves
site which gives us a sneak peek at
season 2 so you'll want to stick around
for that we have lots to cover
but before we do make sure to like and
subscribe so you're notified as soon as
one of my raised by wolves videos
drops and what would a raised by wolves
episode be like if it didn't start off
with a little self-mutilation
marcus's nightmares continue as he cuts
away at the flesh holding him together
just like he's cut away at the person he
used to be he's really gone from
non-believer to full-on jack torrance in
about eight episodes one of the things i
noticed here is that black spot on the
wall we saw last episode is still there
if you haven't seen my episode 6 and 7
breakdown
i talk about how it could be revealing
one of those giant snakes
paul visits his father where he learns
marcus believes he's being punished by
saul
i got out of line so soul had to punish
me
remember that marcus was going to kill
mother by throwing her down one of the
holes but the voice which he believes to
be saul
told him not to whatever this voice is
wants
mother alive and this may have something
to do with that baby in her
and the polyhedron but we'll get to that
in a bit
campion is still haunted by tally this
is the only scene we'll see her in for
these two episodes and i think it's just
a reminder that she wears one of those
black
hoods just like we'll see those black
hooded characters in mother's scan of
the tarot cards hunter is asked to fix
father and learns that his twitch
isn't a malfunction at all rather morse
code a code that
translates to saul is the light hunter
will later use this code to revert
father back to his normal self but why
would the password be
sol is the light if he were programmed
by an atheist
is this some factory setting when he was
initially created by the mithraic
or is there more to champion sturgis his
programmer
than we're led to believe mother is
still wounded from her beating by marcus
and
near-death experience by the whole she's
found her way to the tail end of the arc
of heaven where she enlists the help of
carl the android medic and i'm like
could they not make these medics a
little more aesthetically pleasing
like do you want carl over here giving
your three-year-old a flu shot
she finds out something is in her
stomach something we'll later find out
is a half-carbon entity
paul and sue devise a plan to go on an
adventure without marcus but this is
really sue's idea to get paul away from
marcus as she's become
increasingly wary of his recent newfound
love for saul
it's a stark contrast the marcus we see
in the episode's flashback where
he tells her he can't go through with
this without her just like how marcus
takes off his face at the beginning sue
says
i'm starting to forget your face she's
losing the man she came here with
to the point she can't recognize him
she's losing
caleb mother uses her eye to reveal this
black sphere within her stomach she'll
later hook herself up to a sim pod by
the wreckage
where she learns from campion that this
is the mission
what you're carrying inside you is the
mission no
it's always been the mission the future
of humanity
is growing inside you so mother
is pregnant but the show never reveals
how she got there or what she's pregnant
with
all we know is that it's half carbon
based and requires blood
we also don't know if she's always had
this in her or if this was something
that was perhaps
planted in her while she was in the sim
but my guess is that it's always been
there and only
when it was activated by campion through
the pod
that it started to grow a few episodes
ago we got this strange sex scene
between
mother and campion this occurred while
she was in the sim
and i can't help but think that this is
what triggered the growth within her the
episode also reveals that there are
other surviving pods to which one could
access the sim
i've hinted this host we've seen a few
episodes ago is some form of champion
sturgis
either in android or alien form hence
why they've kept his face hidden
he's been waiting for the perfect time
to trigger her child
i've been alone for so long nothing
i had almost given up hope one of the
interesting things here is that mother
initially rejects the
child saying that she doesn't want it
it's ironic since just a few episodes
ago she had to tell tempus that a
child is a gift even if it was given to
you without your consent
mother thinks that carl will have some
answers as to what's growing inside her
after all she was made by the mithraic
carl is mithraic tech 2
but the mathiac technology came from
encrypted discoveries found in their
scripture
they didn't create it per se rather
stole it from these texts
so they know how to make the tech but
not the underlying principles of what
makes it work
it's basically the show's way of saying
hey we're going to hold out a few more
episodes until we tell you what's going
on
mother needs to find more fuel to feed
the fetus growing inside her
she sniffs around like a wolf and we've
seen her act like a wolf
several times throughout the season
after all the show is called
raised by wolves she's attacked by one
of the creatures and uses her scream but
doesn't have her necromancer eyes in
remember they're with marcus who will
end up with one in his mouth at the end
of episode 9.
she'll find that the creature blood can
be used to satiate the fetus
tempus will show up after having trailed
her last episode
she is told to get away from her likely
because mother knows her caregiving
program for this new fetus
has overridden even her basic survival
programming which is very odd
if that's the case she may kill anyone
for blood including the children she was
sworn to protect if it means saving the
thing
growing within her i'm also wondering
when mother entered the sim a few
episodes back
and asked if there was something else in
there something she was told was
non-human and non-android
whether that could have been referring
to her baby previously i guessed that it
was the host and i still think it is
but i want to throw all the options out
there the relationship between paul and
marcus deteriorates when sue goes to
save paul
and ends up being locked in one of the
carbo silos
forgive my wife
she has lost away champion escapes with
a little help from paul and creates a
diversion by burning down the mithraic
church
allowing sue hawley vita paul and
campion to make a run for it
tempest returns to the ark to find her
rapist otho among the ruins
he either escaped or was let go after
the failed attempt to kill mother a few
episodes back
since marcus offered him his freedom for
doing the job we get our first shot of
what it looks like inside
the helmet but before tempest can kill a
rapist she's stopped by mother mother
finds out she can use otho as a blood
bag to feed her fetus and now this show
has officially gone
all mad max marcus has basically turned
into what otho was a few episodes back
a crazy believer who no longer hears the
voice of saul
i did all you wanted me to
now come on he believes if he can get
back to that polyhedron temple
seoul will speak to him there paul and
champion seem to be best buds again
especially after this mishap a few
episodes ago
how could you do that paul shows
champion his mouse claiming its
existence
is proof that saul exists it dropped
down the hole and now is magically
backed by the grace of saul
campion says tally is back too she
apparently fell down the hole as well
but this version of her is evil remember
she told campion to kill himself
does this mean we have an evil mouse too
as soon the kids move into the tale or
the ark there's a great little chat
about the tooth relic and the ancient
story of romulus and remus
two twin brothers who were raised by a
wolf and founded the city of rome
it feels very much like paul and campion
are romulus and remus here with mother
as the wolf however the boys aren't
twins
tempus asks how mother got pregnant
that's beyond my understanding
my creator made it possible
you sound religious suddenly nonsense
and this type of immaculate conception
mother seems to be going through
totally draws parallels to christianity
as i've said in my other videos the
mithraic religion derives many of its
customs from
christianity mother tempest and otho are
drawn to these metallic tarot cards
hanging by the side of a cave
almost as if someone is wanting them to
come across it we even get this pov shot
of what appears to be someone watching
them
this has to be the host since it was he
or it who grabbed the tarot cards from
the mathrake a few episodes back
whatever these cards are
they're important enough for the host to
risk his life to get them
other remarks that he's seen these cards
on earth used by the devil [ __ ] before
we purge
later mother will scan one of them the
one with the shadow figures on it and it
reveals something similar to the
archived memory she had with campion
it's what appears to be a memory
depicting several hooded figures around
a polyhedron
at the center is an alien creature which
appears to be spewing
something similar to android blood
giving it a closer look i'm not certain
if it's either breaking out like it's in
some sort of egg
or if it's being contained like a prison
i'm interested to hear what you guys
think below but more striking is its
shape similar to that of the large
polyhedron which will later spare
hunter's hand did this death cult otho
mention worship an alien creature that
is locked away within these polyhedrons
is it this alien creature that is
pulling the strings of all our
characters that's the voice controlling
them in what will eventually turn out to
be an effort to gain its freedom
in an ancient roman mystery religion
that is called guess what
mithraism the god they worship mithras
is said to have been birthed from a
stone
a stone that sometimes emits flames
sound familiar
we do know whatever is controlling this
voice wants mother alive
and perhaps it's because she possesses
the only thing that can open it her
voice
her scream is the only thing powerful
enough to break it
open the only thing is a mother does not
have her eyes that allow her to turn
into the necromancer those are held by
marcus he loses the trust of the
mathraek after killing dorian
in my last video i discussed how the
backstory between marcus and lucius's
father
would likely come back to bite marcus in
the ass and
it definitely did lucius is able to tell
that marcus
isn't who he says he is because a real
mathraek would never pray for the soul
of the impure something marcus said he
did for lucius's father after executing
him
lucius ends up beating marcus to near
death stuffing his mouth with the
necromancer eyeball as foam streams out
of his mouth i
highly doubt they're going to kill off
marcus here he'll be saved but the
question
is by whom everyone seems to be out of
the pitcher but the host and i can't
help they set him up for nothing without
paying him off in the finale
he probably doesn't care about saving
marcus rather wants that eyeball that's
in his mouth
so that he can give it back to mother so
she can get her power back a power which
may be used to open the polyhedron
otho is somehow able to reverse the flow
of the fetus blood which gives him crazy
power in the lander father picks up this
power on the transmitter and says it's
on par with mothers both those
outsmarted by holly and tempest who are
able to throw the guard's head away
which
prompts the can on his head to crush him
alive paul secretly destroys the metal
tarot cards likely because he believes
them to be the work of a devil cult
just like otho did now i'm not sure how
much damage a small fire like this will
do against metal but it may be enough so
that mother can't
access the data hidden on them i should
also point out these symbols here which
don't appear to be
english and i'm also a little bit upset
we may never see what other cool
mysteries are on the other cards
hbo max has also released a cool
interactive map
which itself has some great easter eggs
i'll leave some links in the description
below once you collect all 30 map
markers you're treated to this screen
for a season 2 sneak peek
you ready
[Music]
yeah those [ __ ] totally rick rolled
me as the link leads to never gonna give
you
up but there's something even more
hidden when you discover 100 of the map
a short raised by wolves comic and this
read the caption here tarantula a large
ship capable of transporting
redacted approach with caution energy
signature unknown
inhabitants currently unidentified now
it's got to be human right look at the
english on the side of the hull and the
two shadowy human figures near the
bottom
is this a group of humans who came to
the planet years before the
ark some have even formulated that the
creatures on the planet are devolved
forms of humans hence why mother is able
to use the blood for her likely
half human baby i'm really hoping the
season finale will give us some much
needed answers
everything seems to have been building
up to something big and i'll be here
next week to break it all down
thanks for watching everyone please make
sure to like and subscribe and leave a
comment with your thoughts and theories
about the show below
you can also follow me on twitter and
instagram at
yt until next time remember daddy loves
you very much